[Music]
take her first few steps
and adores the father who's constantly
by her hospital bedside now
her ears nose and mouth almost
everything needs reconstructing
and she can't talk because of the tube
in her throat helping her breathe
she is a mass of red raw scars her hands
amputated
but to her father she's beautiful and to
the doctors
she's a miracle we first reported on
dalal at the start of the year
she was rushed over to turkey from idlib
in syria
covered head to toe in burns
the doctor said she had a 10 chance of
pulling through
because it's a very great deep burning
and i saw the figures were was
four degree black just like coal
dalao her five siblings and parents were
asleep in their tent in idlib when it
caught fire
set alight by the stove they were using
for heating
despite desperate attempts to pull them
to safety her ten-year-old sister died
and dalal was horribly burned
we've monitored her progress closely and
by last month
with surgeries almost every few days she
was still
hovering between life and death
but she has come through it all
she communicates with clicking noises
mimicking her father's kisses
and holding up what's left of her hand
to receive them too
as well as her foot
the doctors planned to discharge her
soon but returning her to a tent
in war-torn syria is abhorrent to them
[Music]
so far all the medical treatments been
provided free by turkey
but her reconstructive surgery will cost
and she faces years of treatment and
years of surgery
her physio maneuvers her arms which are
already seizing up with the skin grafts
she's had
painful to watch painful to endure
painful to carry out
turkey's hospital wards are filled with
syrian victims
more than four million refugees are now
camped inside the country
dalal's life is not going to be easy
she's going to spend it struggling
but her plight has already prompted
donations from british viewers
which will help cover rent on a small
flat for her and her father
and the doctor who treated her first
says she's cheated death
three times he cannot believe how far
she's come
this is the third time we are together
and then
i said yes you can go girl you can go
besides
all these periods can be called miracles
not just once all the period is a
miracle
for my opinion as a doctor and we don't
like to say miracles you know
but it's a miracle yes isn't it
isn't it we are going to change your
name
miracle lady
dalal responds immediately when she sees
her mother and siblings on a video call
from their tent in idlib
dalal and her father have only temporary
protection in turkey but the rest of the
family do not
and the doctors believe her best chance
of recovery and the only chance to get
the surgery she needs
is to be with all of them away from the
wall
alex crawford sky news in merson
southern turkey